okay so my name is david konapo
and i will be
trying to
explain a bit about using databases for
scientists with my colleague simon
um so first to talk a bit about myself
ourselves um so i've been involved in
the python scientific committee for
quite a while some people may know me
through i've been like the risk manager
for numpy for a while i've been doing a
lot of like c code
refactoring numpy sci-fi
i've been starting what became psychic
learn he started to be popular when i
stopped working on it i try not to be
angry about it but
um
and um yeah i've been working at insead
for three years now um so instead of the
company doing scientific consulting for
python
and
we've been working with simon on some
projects in finance industry and some
other things
okay um someone maybe you want to say a
few what about yourself before we start
um i'm simon jagger i've been
working for nthot for about three years
as well
working
on developing
scientific applications more on the
application development side rather than
the science
side
and been working with python for that
sort of thing for about six years
okay so
so this talk that we'll be doing uh
today is actually a kind of extended
version of something i did two years ago
at the first pi data
so the idea is i myself more like a
scientist
you know i did my phd in
uh speech recognition in japan
and
so i don't know exactly what the
audience here is but as a scientist
database for me that was this horrible
thing to do
business report and
things that you don't want to hear about
when you're academic right
and
after my phd i started to work for a
small company in japan doing like
recommendations and of course you have
to deal with databases because that's
what people use
and i realized that database is actually
quite interesting even for the
scientists and i searched for business
report
and
there is a bit of this divide between
people using databases and people using
like numpy pandas all these kind of
great tools
and it's not always obvious which one to
use
as a scientist some of you is why you
would use databases
so
what you're trying to convey here a bit
is like it's not really like numpy
versus data but it's much more about
how we can try to
in which case it doesn't make sense to
use databases in which case it makes
sense to use numpy how we can use numpy
pandas etc from databases because
sometimes you have to use databases just
because the data is in a database and
your manager is asking you to get some
data from this
microsoft sql server data and but you
don't want to touch database you just
want to use pandas
so we'll talk a bit about that
sometimes some people who are not
scientists who are not like
don't really know about data science
they know about sql
so sometimes you want to do the opposite
right you have some pandas data frames
and like okay planet is great but if you
don't really know much about pandas or
python and your word is sequel is there
a way to create data frames using sql
so we'll talk a bit about all of this um
not really in detail because you only
have one hour
but hopefully we will manage to give you
a bit of an idea
of what's available out there and the
different tools you can use
with a band on like the python
philosophy of you know
how to use simple tools that works well
and can be extended to do like
non-trivial things
so if i do that does it work here
so
really the the first thing is we are
using databases at all because again
that's the example of a scientist so
okay
scientists
you have
you know about numpy et cetera and you
really like to do data analysis with
numpy and powders because that's what
you're familiar with
and basic arrays is what you know
there's all these things about data
types it's all floats and like maybe
integers but like basic numerical data
types
so to justify a bit why you should care
at all about database
we have here one of the
simple but not completely artificial
example of some data analysis on stack
overflow
i think pretty much everybody is
familiar with stack overflow right
yeah so stagger flow is this website
that happens a lot when you look for
programming problem in google
so
one cool thing about stack overflow is
that they make the data available for
you um
you can download a bittorrent
you actually did use that um you have a
20 gigabyte of compressed data of all
the stock exchange
data where you have like the posts the
questions the comments
almost all the information that is in
the databases of stack overflow website
you you have it available for yourself
so you can do some data analysis
on that
and so since there is public available
maybe you want to look a bit at
maybe what are the popular tags okay
popular tags that's not so useful not so
interesting because you get that already
on the stack of upload website but maybe
you want to look at the trends of the
tags over time
and so again your scientists i mean
myself a few years ago what i would have
done is create some xml file that's the
format of
stack overflow i have none by arrays and
i will do that
premise that's a 23 gigabyte xml file
and you have like around 18 minutes
question on the main stack overflow
website
so
the well-known technique of brute force
will not work exactly
as well as you would like on the laptop
at least it was a few years ago as well
so yeah it's too large to use pandas on
a laptop
and the other interesting part is you
don't have just one large xml file you
have like a few large xml files there
are things like you have posts
and you have tags but maybe you have
like some
independent information on another xml
file and they're linked together through
a relation
is coming from a sql database
and it's not clear how you would do that
in empire
when you don't have enough ramp to do
just everything brute force
so the idea here is
maybe you can store the data in your
database because right
one big advantage of database is it
gives you the idea of
out of core computation where
even on a laptop having 200 gigs of data
assuming you have enough hard space hard
drive space of course
it's not a lot of data
so while we not talk about big data in
our talk
2gig is not big data right
like 200 gigs is not big data sometimes
you see some people some blog posts
talking about big data mongodb with five
gigs and
one it's not exactly a big data so stack
overflow so we imported the data in
postgres
um
because we are a bit short on time we
didn't manage to import everything
but we had a table which was around
about 10 gigs
if you know that so we had like half we
didn't have like 18 million questions
but you had like around 8 million
questions and you had like let's say
5-10 gigs all of magnitudes of data
in the database so it's enough not to be
trivial to handle on a laptop at least
and so the idea is
we have just there in the database
but we want to plot things like what are
the trends in the tags over time
and what we do not want to do is using
excel to import the data right we're
going to use pandas matlab lib to do
everything in the notebook because
there's the tools you're familiar with
so the whole point of this talk is to
show you a bit different tools to be
able to handle this kind of problem
where you have data we have char
not big enough so you need like
distributed computing all the fancy
things that you can see in the other
talks
everything is on one machine
but it's big enough that you cannot do
it brute force with pandas or numpy and
we show a bit how you can use those
tools
to do this kind of task
something i should have asked before
studying is
how many people know quite a bit about
sequel in the room
it's quite a bit and how many people
knows quite a bit about pandas numpy
okay
so you don't need to just use it
okay so
hopefully some of you will learn
something
so we'll talk a bit about
how to uh deal to import data from
postgres into pointers
so postgres in case not everybody knows
so postgres is one of the well known
open source database like the two big
ones are my sequel and postgres
and postgres are some interesting
features um
it doesn't create the data for once
and also like it's it has a few things
that allows you to deal with non-juice
relational data but some other things as
well
we'll learn a bit about how you sequel
alchemy to deal with databases because
sometimes it's actually pretty rare to
start from a database what happens
sometimes often is that you have a
database already there because that's
what another team will use in your
company
and we'll have a database with like
hundreds of tables with of course
absolutely no documentation and the guy
who
knew about the schema he left years ago
anyway so
the only chance to be able to handle
this data is to use something like for
example sql alchemy to kind of load the
data for you and to avoid
for you to have to look into a database
directly
by yourself
we'll talk a bit about how to spawn that
sequel to do kind of the opposite so you
have some pandas data frame
and
sometimes it's not
easy to remember exactly how to do some
complex operation in pandas or maybe you
juice more familiar with sql so there is
it's a cute little tool
that was created last year by the team
from ihat
where you can basically execute some sql
but in a panda data
frame and we'll talk a bit about how to
handling how to handle semi-structured
data in postgres so like
not data which are all exactly the same
type but enough differences that you
cannot use normal tables
a normal relationship in a sql world
but like semi-structured data more like
a document word like
like a lot of people like to use mongodb
because gb et cetera
but actually you can do quite a bit in
pure postgres
through something called extra
so yeah with all that we will not talk
about very large data so if it's what
you're looking for you can leave right
now we're not talking about data
and we'll not talk about all the cool
things like scalability etc so we'll
talk about boring
things
to
to do the job
okay so
i've been talking for like like 10
minutes about database and etc
but
again especially if you're a scientist
it's not very clear what a database is
if you ask more like a programmer
someone who's done like java for 15
years you're asking what is databases
sql server is db2 etc so
if you're coming from this world it's
pretty clear but if you're more like
a scientist
like a database you know
again this thing that you know other
people use but you don't want to touch
that
so if you look into wikipedia what is
the database the database is an
organized collection of data from one or
more purposes usually in digital form
so okay
so is an empire is a database because
it's organized collection of data right
so maybe
maybe an empire's database
same for pandas
csv5 is it a database it's organized
collection well hopefully organized
collection of data
so
again if you ask most programmers what
is the database an example they will
talk to you about mysql postgres oracle
et cetera
so
i try to expand a bit on this definition
from wikipedia
so do you say that my sequel postgres
database and csv and empire are not
because there is a creating language
so in csv there is nothing right but
it's just a file format
numpy is some kind of querying right if
you want to say you have an array of
integers and you want to ask give me all
the integers that are positive from this
array you can use fancy indexing and
this works well
but that's pretty basic creating
language
is it maybe a database because of data
modeling so
when you talk about again numpy arrays
or csv files the modeling is pretty
simple in the sense that
you have a set of columns maybe
or maybe you just have one type
and you have a lot of entries so
for example before pandas what was
pretty common in the numpy world was
let's say you have some data
some climate data where you have like
some temperature across different
locations
one thing you could do is to create a
structured array right so structural
arrays this thing where you have a d
type which is a compound of atomic type
so you have a d type which is not just a
float an integer but that's a d type
which is
10 20 floats because we have 20
locations to look at for your
temperature
so you have some kind of basic data
modeling here right
one other issue is let's say we don't
want just data but metadata
that's where it's numpy starts to be
quite limited like if you want some
metadata on top of this data like you
have 10 or 20 columns
but maybe
you want to have some metadata attached
to each of this city
so what you could do is to have some
separate arrays or some
separate dictionary
and model your data a bit like that
and that's what a lot of people do
that's only what i used to do
quite a bit
this works but it feels a bit
dirty and if it doesn't we'll explain a
bit while later
the last part which is maybe the most
obvious one is storage
so one reason why people may not be
interested in database when they're
coming from a scientific background
again this was my case is
people say diabetes are really fast and
everything and you start like some basic
things like
i have 10 million entries and i want to
look at the sum maybe in numbers nothing
right i mean as long as the numpy array
is in memory
it's like it's
you type the command and come take
taking right away if you try to do that
in a database it's not always obvious
that it will be fast maybe you need some
index maybe sometimes even with index is
not that fast
but one of the things that is really
critical to database and that's kind of
what convinced me that databases were
actually useful even for the scientists
is the idea of storage
because okay an empire ways they're
really fast
and one of the reasons they're fast is
because the data is in one big block
right
so the fact that everything is one big
block is why numpa is really fast and
why number is not very flexible in the
sense that
if you want
um
for example
multiple
you have like a file backed
um file backed an empire way maybe using
a map arrays
if you're multiple writer to the same
data it doesn't work really well right
you correct your data so maybe you can
take care of like different array
different processes right into different
parts of your name by array
and this works fairly well but what if
you need a lot of concrete accesses if
you start to handle that by yourself
that's pretty painful
some people were a bit naive again
myself a few years ago
you know like you don't realize that
when you use like simple files and you
try multiple processes to write the same
file while the operating system doesn't
guarantee anything for you right you
will corrupt the data most likely or you
will create the data
so that's one of the things that
databases are really really good at
and one of the big point of databases is
they have a complex storage layer where
they can handle a lot of different
writers and readers to the same file
well i mean you actually don't see the
file in much the same set of files
because at the end of the day it's on
the hard drive right but you don't see
that directly as a sql database user
it's really
all about abstracting parallel writing
parallel reading
concurrency is handled for you
so that's kind of one big point of
databases
and
obviously when you have csv files on
empire ways that doesn't work right if
you have a csv file and you want to edit
the csv file you want to store that back
to the file system
if you try to handle that correctly by
yourself you will end up implementing a
very poor database right databases are
exactly about that
what happens often in reality is when
you use numpy csv file basic like
flat file storage
is that you will end up
just storing your data back and forth
between files you will copy data and in
a certain order maybe because you want
to access them quickly
and for some
as long as you're the only one working
on it for some cases it worked pretty
well but again when you need different
people or different
programs accessing the same data the
chance for encryption is pretty high
that's because of storage and also
because of data modeling
that's one thing with databases can be
pretty good
okay
so
to explain a bit on all that so you've
seen
what is the database so there's the
creating language with the data modeling
and laser storage
so curving that's actually not so true
anymore
and when i did my presentation a few
years ago it was kind of true in python
world but
it's not really true anymore
and why it's not true is here we have a
simple example where i'm using pandas
panda sequel
here you have some bit of panda sequel
shim that really looks explained here
and
here i have some basic
data from the python dev mailing list
so i have basically the topic
the sender and the date for each email
of the pydev mini list
in a csv format
and
what i would like to do is
well maybe i want to see
the number of
emails per
sender
using a data frames so
here sorry here pydev is my data frame
right under the frame i have two columns
from column well actually here we only
care about one column from call
which is the sender of the email
and we have some basic sql
where we select we have a simple group
by right we want to get the count of
emails
pair sender
so we write simple sql here
and we found a sql
well basically with just this command we
get back a data frame that give us
exactly the count per uh
sender so
to answer the first question is it a
database because of the queen language
well yes or no right because you can do
this kind of things
very easily
in python and some other languages
storage
so
as i explained before
when you have an empire raise
or pandas arrays but for that doesn't
really make a difference
when you save it to a
data format
most likely if a simple data format like
whether there is a binary format of
numpy
hdf5 this kind of things
where j5 is a bit more advanced already
but
basically it's you have one big file and
everything in it
so database works very differently
it's a database so that's very
simplified version of database but
basically the
main idea in database is you store
things
in things you can call pages for example
you have like different pages
and generally this corresponds to the
size of one page of your operating
system but always so the other might use
it's a few k kilobyte
and you put the data in there but it's
not contiguous that is when you have the
starting point
you will have like some pointer to the
next block and each block knows how to
go to the next and you have actually
some hierarchy in some data structure
called b3s
which allows you to find things very
quickly
so the fine here is the key
like in databases
you don't have to
put everything sequentially which means
that from a pure throughput point of
view it will definitely be slower than
numpy and pandas
but on the other hand
you want to append like one percent of
data to some data in a database but it's
fairly easy because there's just adding
one block
if you have an empire raise of 100
million entries you want to add one
million entries well
only real choice is really to create a
new empire race and put everything
so it's part of the storage idea that
databases
can do things better here when you need
to edit back and forth data
and to search for data more efficiently
the other thing that i will not talk
much about is databases know a lot about
io and how to do io efficiently
numpy definitely doesn't
panders i'm not sure whether it's a bit
smarter for like reading like text file
and things like that but numpy is really
dumb for all the basic i o functioning
in numbers
and because most of the io is based on
single files reading and writing
concurrent reading and writing
if it doesn't work at all with numpy or
pandas dealing with random io that
doesn't really work well either
databases are much better at handling
this kind of thing
so if you need like a large data which
are larger that your ram or if you need
data where you know you need to modify
them quite often
databases is often a more appropriate
storage story at least than pure number
the last part is the data modeling
so
that's another idea that i didn't really
know about
as a pure scientist
is again taking this example of
climate data
so you have maybe 10 or 20 measurements
for 20 different cities and maybe you
have i don't know like 100k
measurements
we need some metadata for the cities
so one thing you could do of course is
to have some dictionaries with those
metadata or maybe some objects with the
metadata for cities and you link them
back and forth with numpy arrays
and that's fairly easy to do in python
the prime is what starts to happen when
you need to store that and give that to
someone else right it's in different
files so it's very likely that if you
start dealing with other people's and
other people including yourself three
months later right
you may have some issue because of data
corruption because you forget that those
things are linked
when you start having different data
you're trying to design different files
experience right tells that
often you'll start to have like
inconsistency and corruption
one of the key points in data modeling
why in sql is to have the data
normalized
that is you try to invest some
like formal definition but we don't have
really the time to go into the formal
definition
but the basic idea of normalized data is
pretty intuitive is you want to remove
the redundancy of the data
and
the whole point of doing that is first
to save some space
on the hard drive but maybe more
importantly to be rugged produced
against deletion and changes in your
data
because again like in this simple
example here where we have like
different
would be like different empire arrays
right and they have some relation so in
our example of um climate data we would
have like some
id maybe for each series and you have
object cities with the media of each
city and you have that kind of relation
between them
but if later you want to ask an empire
where you want give me the 100k data
and for each data give me the metadata
of the series because it's easier to
handle
in numpy your only way is really to copy
everything
databases reviews etc can do things a
bit better here
okay so there was a bit of a long
introduction
to try to
to convey the idea that vase
like a word that is outside an empire
and pandas where you can use databases
to do
different things
those things include data larger than
memory
things where you need to be smart about
the file io storage the storage layer
story or you need concurrent access both
in reading and more importantly in
writing
and when you need to be able to edit
your data back and forth
because numpy and pandas are not really
great tool to deal with that
issue so
a bit more concretely now is to look at
some tools to to do these kind of things
because okay maybe you're convinced that
you should use some databases because
you have some data that require
databases
but how do you do that in python how to
use that with numpy responders
so one of the first tool that is
not mandatory but
is almost
always the right tool to use for
database in python is to use sql
algorithm
here we go
okay so since pretty much everyone is
familiar with databases i will skip
quite a few examples and
how many of you know nosql alchemy
okay so it will be very quickly
um so
so sql alchemy
is um
so one definition is um
it's pretty good one is it's a database
toolkit so it's not just object
relational mapper but
it's actually not the most interesting
part of sql alchemy it is a one
interesting um thing with sql alchemy is
the layer the design that is you don't
just have object relational mapper
because sometimes using object rational
mapper
gives you
give you a lot of abstraction but
sometimes you have some issue in terms
of performances
so the maybe strongest selling point of
sql alchemy is that you can go one layer
down
to use something that's correctly called
the co-expression language right where
you don't use objects or classes but you
class and you don't model your tables by
classes
but you
deal directly with stable tables
so here just for the people also
familiar with sql alchemy the point is
not to talk about the sql alchemy api
but we need to talk about how you would
use
sql alchemy
for some databases
so here for simplicity we use sqlite
because that's already available in
python another box
we connect to
this is a syntax to say we want to
in-memory database
we create our in-memory database
and we create a set of
tables but here only one table
where we call cities and that's a very
simple data where we have some city with
something in the
with a corresponding state
and a population
how many people you have in this city
so create all here we just ensure that
the table is created
and with sql alchemy you can start to
connect to the database and to insert
some data so you say
so again the data is not really
interesting here but i mean you insert
the population of los angeles in the
state of california
and so
what sql alchemy gives us here is some
abstraction because
we don't care about sqlite excel for the
first line
all of this would work in most sql
databases supported by sql to me
the other thing that is nice is you can
pass dictionary
here
you can't do that with pure db api too
from python
and here we just insert some data and
then you can do some basic
secret operation so for example if you
want to use the name of every city you
can have this basic um secret sql
alchemy operation where each sql
operation
is
abstracted
in python so you never write sql as text
right you really have like python
function the actual object you can deal
with them programmatically so it's much
better than just using raw sql
so the other thing i wanted to look at a
bit
some issue with this
is the object relational mapper level so
this is the highest level available in
sql alchemy
when you deal with large data for like
kind of data analysis
sometimes there's too much to do that
but sometimes it can useful like simon
later will show some examples where you
use the om directly to import some data
so the basic idea is fairly simple so
you have some tables the same table as
before where you have the table city
where i have some
name for the city as a population and
the name of the state
so the way to model that is fairly
simple in sql alchemy you first have a
class factory a declarative base
so
often
conversion is to call that class base
and then you subclass each new class
that represents an object you want to
model you want to map to sql will be a
subclass of base
table name here is to specify the name
of the table
because maybe you have some existing
databases that you want to put the
object relational mapper on top of and
here we have the different columns so
here id name
and here are the name state id and
population
when you use the object relational
mapper
again we won't go into the details but
just so people who are not familiar with
sql alchemy can still follow the
examples later from simon
you create sessions
and session is how you
can
write you create some objects and you
write them to the database recession
object and when you want to fetch some
data from the database and create the
objects based on reception as well
and so here that's an example on how to
do
things for again some simple data in csv
format i'm going to import in the
database
we read the data with the csv the
standard library of python
and we just create
passing the data we create some objects
as we would create normal python object
and we add them to the session
we do the same for cities and once we're
done we have only a few words each so
you just do everything and we commit at
the end
so once we commit once the commit is
successful
then the data is written in the database
once you have data the database you can
start creating them
the way to query them in
from sql alchemy is again through the
session object
session query and you want to create
object
from the class city and here you just
went all the cities
so we get back to this instance right so
we got
those things here
right
and then since we have simple objects
you know we know how to do that with
python because we know python and we can
just look at the name attribute the
state id population etc
of course in general you don't want to
load everything um you want to load
things according to some criterion and
then you will use the filter function
and the way sql alchemy is designed is
pretty neat it allows you to like kind
of pipe in a sense like filters just
using function composition
and we filter
so here i will talk about the later but
maybe we want just all the cds that are
from texas
and here i get jesus series from texas
there is a mistake here someone
mentioned before i need to fix arlington
i think he's not in texas
yeah maybe there's several but yeah
i'm not very
knowledgeable about american geography
okay so
that's the basic idea of the object
rational mapping sql alkene
you have your classes
often but not always one class per table
and here so i have my state
and my cities
and that's the first example of this
normalization idea i mentioned before
since most of you are familiar with sql
you know about the normalization
but just as a small reminder
so we have
the name of the
state and what you would do for example
if you are in numpy let's say you have
an empire way where you have one rule
per cd and you have a column which is a
name
and a column which is a population use
structural way to do that and you have a
column with the state name the problem
is you have to repeat the state name all
the time right if you have ten cities
from texas you have to repeat texas ten
times
the problem is what if somewhere later
you want to change text to texas well
you need to do that everywhere
if
you're not careful or exactly when
you're not careful
you will
most likely get some corruption because
of invalid data exactly because
you have this redundancy here
so the reason we have a separate cities
state class here sorry
is because
in cities if you were careful you didn't
have the state name but the state id
the state id refers to the other table
and state so that we have a table state
where you have only like the state so 50
states in the u.s
and if you want to change text to texas
we only have to change exactly one row
because all the cities that mentioned
texas they will not mention it through
the name but through some id
here
this is the kind of thing you cannot do
in empire or pandas really
because of the way like you always have
one a bit like one big table
to use a secret
vocabulary you have like denormalized
data
the normalized data is not bad
it can be nice for speed reasons for
like easy
handling reason
but you have this trade-off that makes
it harder to have always consistent data
so
if you reach from your sql alchemy there
is not much new here
but for the people who weren't like the
idea was used to give you a bit enough
about sql alchemy so you can follow the
more interesting example that simon will
talk about
so the idea is you have two layers core
to abstract the sql
and then you have the above layer where
you map objects to tables
you know someone will talk about how to
use sql alchemy and a bit of pandas to
actually do some
not just talk about cities but about
stack overflow there's some interesting
data from stack overflow
so david mentioned at the start the
stack overflow tags
on the posts
and
the trend and popularity of various tags
which is the
basic example that i'm going to go for
but first
just the importing of
uh
stack overflow data from
these
xml files
they ship a handful of xml files for
each
stack exchange site
i chose
something that wasn't too big because
running on a little laptop here i don't
have
a terabyte of ram to play with
i chose the second largest which is the
meth.stackexchange.com
which
that's the data they give you so there's
two gigabytes of data for
uh the distant second
site of stack overflow which is
uh
if i remember correctly about 600 000
posts which pales to 18 million of stack
overflow
if we look at
the data
we've just got this
pretty nasty looking
xml document
it's very straightforward one row per
post
easy enough to parse into either a data
frame or a database but assuming we're
working with a large amount of data
we go into a database
where is my
okay i don't know why i'm
let's kill my startup file
okay i don't know where my emacs has
gone we'll uh
use something slightly less less
exciting
and of course that's what's going on
sorry about that
so
um
we've got
i've only loaded a small portion of the
data uh just a very simple relation
which is the relationship between the
posts and all of the tags
so there's a many-to-many relationship
we've got
each person can have multiple tags and
obviously the same tag can be applied to
multiple posts so
instead of denormalizing that like you
would in a numpy array or a data frame
i've split those out into two separate
separate tables and
built a simple relationship
what i like about this is that the
database schema looks pretty simple
i'm not a big fan of sql myself
i like
the sort of definition
and that's just
everything that you can find in
the posts
is what you might expect which forum
it's from so
methodology exchange or stack overflow
the creation date the actual content of
the
the question is the body
and that's about all we're going to care
about
uh for this
um
so that's actually a pretty small
definition there a small schema
the
importing code is
slightly more involved although the only
most of it is the sort of mapping from
what's in the xml to what's going in the
database the column name
and the data type which we have
a separate mapping down here the actual
code for loading
is
simply
we pass an xml file and we expect it to
be large so we iteratively parse it row
by row
and we do an import row by row which
we use our two mappings to the
correct column name and the data type
and
session.add like david
introduced you to
and
just in the case of something going
wrong i commit every thousand rows which
turned out to be a good idea when
importing stack exchange um stack
overflow
it stopped at about eight million rows
for reasons unknown
so actual import code with sql alchemy i
think is very simple
that was
a matter of minutes
putting that together
which
gives us a
database of
so
that gives us
our tags so now we just into
pandas
we've got our tags and
just use pandas to analyze that find the
most popular tags
we've got
what you might expect in a mathematics
forum some number theory some
integration probability
and
homework turns out to be the most
popular
topic
so
well when that came out i had to play
with that a little bit
um it's probably the most simple thing
you can do just um
group by the date and
uh
see
how many posts on each day we've got
from
people asking for
somebody to do their math homework for
them
and
i quite like that graph it's a bit noisy
but
you can see some
definite periodic
cyclic trends
probably when people
leave school and
end of term they don't have any math
homework for other people to do
but
clean up the noise okay would actually
be more trivial to do it in pandas but
assuming we've got a very large
data set again we go back to sql
and just
change how we select the date so
we truncate at the month so we get
monthly data
and do exactly the same thing again and
we land up with
a
more easy to see
period so
tails off until september and then
everybody goes back to school and
they've got more homework again
so you can see
quite clearly though
the cycles there
now that was actually a really simple
example because i did the same thing
just loading the xml into
pandas directly
the posts xml
like we saw here that's
600 megabytes i think anybody can do
that now
um
slightly more
tricky one we've got eight million
rows here
could still
probably get in my memory on this laptop
but it starts to push the balance a bit
so we've got eight million rows
this is the full
stack exchange
what you might expect various libraries
languages
apparently c-sharp is
either popular or people have a lot of
problems with it
and i've not updated that properly
so
pick multi-threading and just the same
again uh
it's become a more popular topic i guess
with multi-core
uh trends and things
that's
just exactly the same thing again
so
um
david do you want to
go on with your edge store
yep
okay so
so
if you summarize a bit what we've seen
like
a little bit how to use
like things like panda sql to use sql
from data frames
made a very brief introduction to sequel
alchemy so you could follow um easily
for people in familiar with sql alchemy
you could follow
the example from simon
it's pretty unfortunate we couldn't see
the example like in real time with the
database we have in cambridge
but
like the stack of afro example where we
have
eight to ten like eight
so i don't make head of several millions
rose
it's not something you can handle
very well um
in numpy and pandas because
well if you just have a few integer
values per rows 20 million rows that's
not much right
but
if you have like textual data like you
have in stack overflow
if you want to start looking at not just
the tags but like the information inside
the post because the database not only
has the tags and everything but also
like
the content of the questions the content
of the
answers you could do like some full text
search kind of things where you could
search not just according to tag but to
like the content of the post and again
because the idea is you don't want to
use sql to do things like plotting and
everything is so much easier to do
pandas so you have your data in the
database
you can use full text search capability
of postgres and then get back
a subset of the data that you care about
as long as the website itself is small
enough you can um
use um pi pandas that are from this term
so okay
the problem is
what happens if you have data which are
a bit less clean because stack overflow
is not it's not super large but not a
trivial is a data set but because the
data were exported
i don't know the structure of
architectural stack workflow but most
likely they're using sql server as well
they just export it to xml
that's well
modeled data set
with tables and everything
but real data set that is coming from
the outside world but it's not as clean
as that right
so one of the prime you have is
this semi-structured data
so what do i mean by semi-structured
data well you think like json right you
have like some json document
coming maybe
the vivids you have some logs
information stored in
in json format
and each entries you expect a set of
keys but not always the same kind of
keys
or maybe you don't even know exactly um
like revised like you know there's
always one or two or three keys but
there are a lot of keys you just have no
idea or maybe you just know all the keys
but maybe the value is not always the
same
you cannot model that very well in
a normal sql database because either
you need to know that all the keys
because you can have some known using
null et cetera but if the set of keys
you're expecting is in the
order of magnitude of one thousand
to start creating sql database with
thousands of columns that's not exactly
how you're supposed to do it
base as of the issue that sometimes the
type of the value is different
so for this kind of things there is edge
store
in postgres
so estro is actually a very very it's
it's a decade old i think extension in
postgres
but that started to make a bit more
noise recently because i did some
features to it that make it very useful
so what is a store
okay
i will go back to that
slide later
so a store is not out of the box in
postgres i guess it may depend a bit on
your operating system but at least on
debian or
ubuntu install
if you want to install
if you want to be able to use a store
we uh
so we'll make the slides available
publicly so you don't need to take
picture if you and you can of course but
we have everything
available
so
you need to install contrib for this
version of postgres to have a store so
postgres93 is the latest released
version of postgres
for each store you want to use a recent
version of postgres it makes a big
difference because of
the new features they add to the store
extension
so
to be able to use extra from postgres
it's fairly simple
once you're in a database you just say
create extension a store
and assuming your restore extension is
strong if you do that you have a story
you can start to use a store
okay
so
what is a strong
so the idea of a store is that it gives
you a key value store in postgres
it gives you all the advantages and all
the disadvantages disadvantages sorry of
a key value store
so when i say key value store means you
have a single column so that's a new
type like int or string of our car etc
there's a single type so you can have
some integer columns some string column
and you have an additional column which
is a store type
the value you put inside this h store
column is
basically a python dictionary right it's
not a python dictionary but it's like
from a structural point of view it's the
same as the python diction
so
here the the kind of data i wanted to
look at
is the email from the python main list
so you can download the archive in the
mbox format
and box format is just a simple text
file
so we have you have like one mbox per
month
so you have one text file per month and
this just
appended each email with the metadata
right like from sender the subject etc
i don't know much about email
format and protocols but
anyway when you get the mbox from pi div
and pi list
each email
doesn't have the same set of keys
so i thought okay but maybe a decent
example of looking at a store
so let's say i importing those data i
pass and box very easy in python
i have
one dictionary
per email
and i store this dictionary as a single
value inside um my extra table
and my table with a store column
so my table here is very simple it's two
columns one id which is a primary key
integer and the other one is called data
which is my store value
so
now what i can do when i have some data
is i can create this data pack
i can select i can say i want to know
how many emails by this guy here at
python
um how many emails you live right on
pythondev
so
i can simply do a count of my values
from pi list my table
and with the work condition
syntax is almost exactly as if from
where a column
but from here is not a column that's one
of the key inside the value inside a
store
in particular i may have some entries
without or from
entry
but here
a store there's a point you can handle
this very easily
so
it's exactly like a document in a
document database right like the basic
feature you have in coachdb and in
mongodb and other document stores is the
same right like when you use a mongodb
api from python what you insert is
documents
so you can do the same kind of things
you have the same kind of disadvantages
right because now
the database doesn't know anything about
form right so if you have two million
rows with a from
key and the value
you need to store
that many rows from
the advantage of course is it well i
don't know if it's an advantage but you
don't have to think much about your data
modeling
and so here i do some count i forgot
exactly how many data i have but it
spice on or personally stores it's not
big it's not completely trivial it's i
think
maybe the order of my two of one million
was
so it's a python list the archive of
for some reason i don't have
they don't make the data before 99
available
but all the emails on the python the
main python main list right
the big traffic main list
for python
i have all the emails from 99 to more or
less well not today but
to january 2014.
so if i want to count how many uh emails
we've written by
this label
i can see okay i can come them
and it takes 200 milliseconds
for a long time that's what you could do
with extra
and you can think okay story is useful
because you can put some kind of
dictionary like value
but you may think well
maybe i could just have used some cell
as maybe i could just use string or
vodka and put like a cell as json inside
it and i stylize back and forth json
you could certainly do that a lot of
people do that they don't do json but
i've seen many cases they produce picon
right they want to store objects in
python they restore the pickled string
in the database and load it back
don't do that
but many people do it
um
here
where it becomes interesting is so i
don't know when exactly i don't know if
it's from nine or nine one
you can create indices on the keys
inside your column
then it becomes
interesting
so
here i can say i'm creating an index on
my table
there are like different type of indices
right here i'm deciding to create a b3
type of index
for
the key from
so what does this mean is that of course
it will take a while well not much
because it's a small table here but it
will go into every row
and it will
see the data
inside my store column my data column
and
we will be able to do a mapping
it's more than a mapping but
my speaking of mapping
so that it can easily get back the
key the value at the key frame
and sure enough if you do the same kind
of
operation as before
which is exactly the same one
you gain two order of magnitude
it takes only like a few milliseconds
so actually timing doesn't really matter
to be honest i didn't do any
serious benchmarking here the scripts
will be available so you can try on your
machine what i'm more interesting is to
see that there's an index and you can
actually see that index is useful
one other thing with a store
is that it's stored as binary
i don't know the details of the data but
it's stored in a way that is efficient
in terms of space and in terms of
speed of access
okay
so it will be quick
okay this will be hard
sorry
that's the other time
oh you mean this one there's the other
tab or
no i can't
oh yeah sorry
and no
this one yeah pretty
okay so
i don't know that keyboard
okay so i have my database emails
where i have two tables
pi dev and pi list
sequences
well for people who are maybe more
familiar in my sequence in postgres in
oracle as well you don't have the notion
of auto increment directly instead you
create sequences which are separate
objects but basically you can ignore
these two like we have to list two
tables pilots and paid f
so
select
from uh so
okay
paydev
so here we can see i have
like
this pie there so the example i should
be is for pi list is for pi day which is
why i have fewer
fewer entries so
if we look at
by dave
so here so slash d is just to show the
schema right in my table
and as i mentioned before it's a very
simple schema we have one type integer
and one type f store
so there's no current form no colon
right
so
select
well let's say from pi dev
where id equal one
just to show one entry
we have the id one of course and
we have the world value right again like
a dictionary
with a date
from
message id
subject
but
until now it's not obvious why that's
actually very useful compared to juicing
back into one column
so it starts to be interesting is you
can do things like that
data
now i'm selecting
all
when not all sorry i'm selecting the
the value for the key from inside my
store
so you can query inside the column store
you can create indices
as well
so
you have actually a lot of operators
available
and i certainly don't know them all but
i forgot is it
okay
i actually forgot the exact syntax um
i mean i'm supposed to have my aid in
front of me but i don't let's see
if i can do that easily
um
and i do not
okay i apologize for that i forgot the
exact syntax of
that operator
there's one um
oh it's juice question mark okay
and
select
and of course
so
what the question mark does is so indeed
just to check which are the entries
where you have the key from
you can even do like partial cr like
partial match where you don't use much
for the exact string from but maybe you
want to look for all the entries where
there is a key that is like something
and depending on which kind of indices
you create on top of that you can get
different
values about the
so
what do you mean exactly what do you
mean exactly by making it known
you mean when you enter the key value
you mean when you enter the value or
i mean there is a there is a field it is
called from
no
i mean oh you mean that the text is
indexed so postgresql
so maybe if i show
my next
sorry here we go
and
like that's how i imported the data so
maybe it will make more sense
so
that's why python comes in
so sql alchemy knows about a store
so since it's of course not standard sql
is specific to postgres you need to
import the postgres direct
in project store and here i'm creating
so a table for pi dev and table for pi
list
here say i have a store
colon
and with a default dictionary
and so here i have like my one inbox per
uh month
just do whatever i need to do it's very
stupid script but um i just do the
import of the inbox and here i iterate
over each email of the inbox
you have a simple dick comprehension to
convert that to a simple dictionary so
you have a dictionary with the key from
and the value
key subject and the value etc
and i enter that
directly
so um
in a recent version of postgres
oh wait is it 93 or is it in dev i'm not
sure no anymore but
um you can actually have like a and you
can have more than one level in the
dictionary you can add dictionary
dictionary with support again for
indices and things like that
but i forgot if it's in the div or if
it's already available in the last nine
three
and so that's
the part to import the data
so here really straight up python
nothing even interesting going on
and
okay
so
i'm afraid i won't be able to execute
the script
so we have to
take my words for it
but that's all you need to import back
the data after you know pandas data
frame
here just create a cycle pg2
connection
and now i want to say give me all the
emails
but which
or more exactly not the emails but those
three values inside the colonnade store
where i have the where i have sorry the
key from the key date and the key
subject
so yeah
i'm a bit afraid of executing the things
here because of the small technical
issues but the basic idea is when you
can it you can um create that into a
panda data frame you can do that of
course for pi dev and for pi list and
then you can look easily at things like
what is the
thread with the most messages
does it happened it's a
python versus lisp is
so thread with the most
number of posts since
the beginning of the archive
and if you look at the person who has
written the most emails
um on the pi dev mailing list you see
that says guido etc and all these kind
of things are very easy to do once you
have these kind of things here
so for pi dev and pi list
it's a bit like some examples that simon
showed with
the math
stack exchange
it's small enough that you actually
don't even really care need to care
about database you could just do
everything in pandas
initially we wanted to do analysis with
a linux scaling manulist but we didn't
manage to get the archive um
but it would have been interesting to do
some basic text search to see the trends
maybe in swearing in the linux kind of
mailing list or things like that
and the next kind of linux kernel
mailing list is big enough
that you cannot just have one big panda
data frame
because the data is too large and
especially if you want to have the text
with it together
i mean at least on a with this letter 16
gigs of ram so
but like on maybe a slightly less
powerful machine it may be a bit too
difficult and if you have more data
anyway then you cannot really do that
anymore
an h-store is um it's a very interesting
i find it a very interesting feature
because
um
in terms of efficiency
it's it's not exactly the same but it's
quite on at least not ridiculous
compared to document databases like
mongodb
and um
db in terms of performances and you get
all the other advantages
you get transaction support you get sql
alchemy support you get all those things
that mongodb and cosdb don't right
and you can use the same store for both
um
so for example from one of the project
internally an insert i'm using a store
um for
some of um
some
for some internal product we're working
on and it gives some interesting um
it's an interesting feature because it
allows you to keep the schema feature
for the tables you really know about and
then less there's more schema
schema-less feature in um
in
the extra and you can migrate from one
to the other as you evolve as well if
you want
okay so we don't have time but that's
good because we're at the end of the
talk
uh
so
so hopefully
it was maybe not very structured talk
but hopefully gave you an idea of the
kind of things you can do using both
databases and by pandas
for example the example that simon
showed where you have the data in the
database but like when you want to plot
things easily it's fairly easy to do in
pandas right so you can do that
very easily with all the features secret
import from pandas and
database feature of either sql alchemy
or even straight up python sql okay
when you have more like less structured
data like document databases well you
can still use postgresql as well with
the app store
facility and one thing is that the hdr
is keep is coming is taking more and
more features
in the next postgres version they are
thinking about adding types information
to the store so you can say this this
value if the key exists
that's an integer that's a bull that's a
string
so
like you get more
like to add more feature like again like
a document database
kind of story so it's pretty interesting
thing if you didn't know about it
anyway thanks for your attention
if you have any question do you have
time for questions no so no questions
we of course you can ask us questions
offline and um
the talk is not online just yet but
we'll put it online tonight just clean
up a few things it'll be on github the
scripts
i will try to put the data uh but not
another stack overflow data
that's on bittorrent but all the other
data csv et cetera and s3 so you can
play with the data and
play by yourself
okay thank you